all right norman yes sir welcome back
glad to be back so where are we at today
you started work about a week ago yes
started work a week ago uh i'm a retail
associate uh
got a nice little promotion last night
as a floor leader you got a promotion
already yes that's great yeah
um they just seen the leadership ability
and um
the knack for knowing exactly what to do
how to do it where to place things
uh it's quite different than what i'm
used to i've never been a retail
associate
you know nice little title you know but
i'll take it and uh
so it's a wonderful company um
damn good benefits they got a lot of
things in there and i really enjoy it
really really enjoy it that's excellent
so and and so you're staying with your
friend don yes
yeah it's my best buddy and uh how's
that i was
he so don uses yeah and you're using or
not
no you're not no so don and like you
mentioned before don kind of like
goes somewhere else the degree of
respectability that he has for me and
what i'm doing
and what i'm trying my best to do you
know is it's
insurmountable i mean he's a great
person and
and it doesn't bother me that he does
what he does you know this is my friend
you know friend is a hell of a word you
know you can have an associate you can
have a partner
but he's my friend you know because when
i really needed some help he was right
there
you know no no strings attached hey man
this is what you need come on you know
and um
of course in my mind i would like him to
you know follow my path but in your own
way
you know it happens in different times
you know i think i quoted the scripture
once before the ecclesiastics 3 1
a time and a purpose and a season for
everything you know it's not his time
you know maybe it's not the purpose it's
not his season maybe it's mine and maybe
by me going through what i'm going
through
to to get where i want to get you know
we'll you know sometime somehow pull him
you know he's his own man he's a grown
man you know and the decisions are made
by yourself you know power choice and
control you lose one
you lose them all that's just my own my
own philosophy
so uh it'll happen for him yeah i know
it will
have you wrapped your head around the
concept that relapses are just part of
the process
yes and there may be more yeah there may
be more who knows um
but i no longer suffer from that
impending doom
you know i don't even count my days
anymore when i when i
when i go to work and i go home i rest i
wake up when i wake up i said thank you
for this day
because i don't want to put too much
pressure on myself not so much that i
know myself
i'm beginning to know a little bit more
about the power
and the insidiousness of the disease you
know
everything will be fine not a cloud on
the horizon
just like that a lot of people don't
understand that and they say why
you know well if we could answer the
question why then probably a lot of
people would be sober
and wouldn't do what they do and a lot
of people wouldn't do the other things
that they do beyond drugs enough
sometimes it's something that something
stressful right but also sometimes it's
something positive will trigger it right
right is it the last
inability to accept the the fortune that
you just came across
well no you know what i really don't
know i can't answer that question
um i had actually you know because i
prided myself on
knowing a lot of things i actually went
to my boss
i think it was tuesday night and i told
him
i don't know and that was humbling for
me
because usually norman knows but i
didn't
know and it wasn't a point of me being
scared or
or something like that or asking them
but i thought to myself when i
when i tried something three times i
said you know what go to the boss this
is something pertaining to work
yes and i just went i love somebody who
i work with who will tell me yeah i
don't know
and what's better than somebody
pretending like they do yes and what
they do is they say
ask questions yeah and they'll always
they'll come around hey norman are you
all right yeah sure
everything's fine yeah sure then they'll
audit you
now i'm running around with a scanner
but they can tap into my scanner and
find everything that i'm doing and at
the end of the night
they they say who's made a mistake who
put something wrong
and they look at the percentages well
you know i've done quite well
you know i've scored 100 percent every
night you know because i pride myself in
doing my best
you know and it's a new experience in
learning so the newness
really really motivates me because it's
something new and i like to learn things
you know so
it's pretty cool i i enjoy it i enjoy it
you know and
we just uh we're going to take it one
day at a time
we're not looking forward because
there's some other things that they told
me last night that could come down
i'm not i'm not looking at that no stay
right here
do what you have to do and just keep
pushing just take it a day at a time you
don't have to look at what's going to
happen
in a month you don't have to think about
what's going to happen in a month
just keep going take it a day at a time
go to work go on your break go back to
work
go to lunch go to work go on your break
go home
rest be ready for the next day
and and trying to break a crack cocaine
addiction without rehab
will be quite a feat right well i know a
lot of people
who didn't go into rehab yeah i know a
lot of people who went uh the religious
route
i know a lot of people just stopped cold
turkey it takes what it takes for a
person you know like i've said before
you know i've been in 50-something
rehabs
um a lot of people had commented on that
too on the page and
you know some good and some bad and that
was okay but you know
it's it's really on the individual it
doesn't matter
where you go okay a treatment facility
will do one
a couple of things it'll house you
that's one
if you're homeless two it'll feed you
some have donated clothes so it'll
clothe you but why am i in that rehab
why did i go to treatment did i really
go to this facility to seek
treatment or was it the fact that
everything got a little bad
i don't rob somebody i'm running from
the law and let me get in here so i can
get a paper sign and go to the court and
they say oh you're in rehab everything's
fine
it's on the person what what do you want
to do dude you really
need treatment there were some people
that commented on the page that said
i needed to get out of the skid row area
and go to treatment well guess what
skid row is just not a place it's a
mentality
that's my own philosophy you can be
living in beverly hills with a skid row
mentality
you can be living in playa vista you can
be living in these
these wonderful communities but you can
have a skid row mentality so it's just
not a place
and guess what if i go to the treatment
center who am i taking with me
me if i leave down from skid row
and go to another state who's taking me
i'm i'm still there
so and for me the kind of acting i
wouldn't give a damn where is that
if i'm going to alaska i'm going to ask
eskimo
so it really doesn't matter where you go
do you have the wherewithal to say
within yourself
i'm tired of this i want something
better today
i do i don't know about tomorrow i don't
know about the next day
but today right now as i'm speaking yeah
i have the wherewithal this is what i
would like to do
excellent i wish you the best of luck
and continue your forward progress
thank you sir always a pleasure to do
another update in a week or two
yes sir all right okay thanks good
damn i kind of listened to myself on
that one
you